okay we're back all right congressman
how do you propose to deal with the
White House's refusal to let its aides
testify before Congress oh yeah that's
the latest obstruction well we're gonna
have to force the issue we're gonna have
to litigate it in court and we're gonna
have to look at other options as well
and that may mean devices we've used in
the past where we cut off funding for
certain offices within certain agencies
if they don't cooperate so we'll look at
whatever tools that we have because at
the end of the day if this president can
succeed in stonewalling the Congress it
means that our power of oversight is
effectively nullified and that will
obviously have serious repercussions
when you have someone who lacks
character in the Oval Office but it will
also repercussions for any president who
follows and so there's a lot at stake in
this fight it's not just over whether a
certain witness testifies it's over
whether we have a system of checks and
balances that still works okay by the
way you go on Fox News girl just told me
he went up at the Comedy Store last
night a comedy store that takes balls
cuz that's not a lot of conservative
audience you do Stan fun yeah did they
laugh how many just we the club we had
it was a about 12 people performing it
it was a conservative slate no everybody
else was talking about sex just regular
I didn't go blow everyone else went deep
blow was it mostly about taxes no taxes
at all Oh
no jokes about taxes okay we're making
fun of the French with the pup making
front of the fridge well we can all get
another piece do you think Stephen Moore
also a frequent guest on our show should
be on the Fed board now Stephen is an
economist like dr. pepper is a doctor
but I think Steve should and I will be
on the on the Fed board besides the fact
that he agrees totally on your page with
taxa he's the you know it's modern taxes
but he's also look he's also for
commodity back currency but does he know
the college central a country central
bank is sort of key at keeping our [ __ ]
together and not having to what is it
unfucked remind the institutions that
are supposed to keep a president
accountable the independent institutions
law enforcement the Fed balance of
powers journalists Trump goes after
these intentionally and constantly and
in the appointment of more is just an
effort to do that you put a crony on the
board of the Fed this is all blood it's
so many stooges you may disagree with
with Moore's policy if sort of no
qualifications you really think he has
the qualifications yeah look he's a
serious guy's a serious student of
economics the tax plan that he put
together turned the economy from one
that wasn't growing very rapidly to
growing at 3% this let today we just
found out the last quarter the economy
grew at three point two percent of GDP
was whether Steve Morse would be on the
Fed which is something that he he is
attacked constantly throughout his curse
do you help write the tax bill that did
that which is more than other people
have done this has nothing to do with
whether or not the qualifications were
sitting on the Fed however it might be
relevant that he made several comments
over the years ridiculously misogynistic
sexist comments shouldn't be female
sportscasters unless they look like
so-and-so or unless they dress like so
these personally yeah I did
these would have been retrograde
positions no this time basketball game
right because it's so annoying to see
women what isn't there a place that men
can go this has nothing to do with
interest rates is there anything you can
do about this stephen moore on the court
i'm the fed bench well you know I share
the view he doesn't belong there he's
not qualified to be there you can't stop
and if you're gonna cite the tax
giveaway bill as a credential that's all
the more reason not to have them in that
position okay Bob Costas what's your
reaction to the right wing's embrace of
Putin considering you are criticized by
people like Rush Limbaugh for being too
favorable towards him in 2014 I remember
that well let's let's start out with the
false premise to begin with right what I
said about Putin among many things said
about Putin in the course of hosting the
Olympics from Sochi was that Forbes not
Mother Jones or the nation Forbes had
named him for 2013 the most influential
world leader dropping Obama to 2 now
naturally the right wing crowd took that
out of context I became a straw man that
became a talking point they ignored the
fact that prior to that and after it I
noted he has the mentality of the former
KGB agent that he was that he's an
international thug that journalists and
dissidents aren't suppressed or worse in
in in Russia they have anti-gay laws
they sponsor repressive regimes like
Syria it didn't make any difference that
I said all those things because that
wasn't useful to their business model
however you look at the way Trump has
cozied up to Putin and all those curious
moments where he could have made clear
that he was an American first and did
not okay but to that crowd it's all a
matter of you know that's that's their
that's their tribe and they cheat at the
Olympics oh they absolutely cheat at the
image they cheated right under the IOC s
nose yes at the Sochi Olympics there
should be no Russian meddling meddling
[Laughter]
John Avlon do you have any thoughts on
why Bill Barr would jeopardize his
legacy to appease Trump it is crystal
clear that he misled the American people
intentionally by putting forward the
most positive spin possible on the
report and and and closing the door on
obstruction and you know at least unless
Congress picks it up I think I think
because there's an Overton Window with
Trump right he didn't nominate Chris
Kobach for AG so all of a sudden bill
bar is comparatively respected if you
look at his record in the Georgia HW
Bush administration this is a play he's
been done before he's done these these
memos that sort of summarize he says
what an underlying opinion says and then
after it's subpoenaed to three years
later you find out actually it's a very
different deal he's clearly making good
on his 19 page memo that he wrote for
the president about about Muller I don't
I think he will go down in history this
will be a real mark not only against him
in the administration but this was a
total distortion and attempt to frame
the debate in a way that's favorable to
the president and it did not represent
the contents than will report you may
not be unhappy they didn't go far enough
but there's a lot there they're 12 open
cases and and I think there's a lot more
investigations that you're gonna be done
in the house about follow the money
another I don't care it felt good to rip
Muller a new [ __ ]
that is so galling about Barr is of
course mother wrote his own summary if
he wanted to give a preview and not wait
until the whole report was out part of
the mother had a summary but the the
whole communication strategy was get
barr out there to misrepresent the
report
why did barr want the job i marvel at
this with so many people who are willing
to completely debase themselves for a
seat at Donald Trump's table and yeah
when when Giuliani first went on the
talkshow circuit as a surrogate of Trump
I wrote a tweet and unlike the president
I have my staff review it to see if it's
insane my draft said you know whatever
happened America's mayor why are so many
people willing to completely debase
themselves recede at Donald Trump's
table and to my staff say you can't
possibly send that out
you can't possibly send that out they
were both New Yorkers and I said why and
they said because he completely debased
himself long before now and they work
for Rudy Giuliani when he was mayor and
I was proud to do it and but but I do
think this is a different chapter I do
think folks I have a tendency to show a
lot of loyalty and fealty to somebody
who which who does not show loyalty in
return and and just your back on on the
bar thing the most egregious thing was
he repeated six times and the pressure
of the day and in the memo the the
exonerating you know the non exonerating
language right the other half of the
sentence said that the Trump campaign
expected to benefit from Russian efforts
to influence the election that's as
crystal clear as again that efforts
ongoing today and Donald Trump is still
in denial yeah it's completely insane
right thank you everybody thank you
[Applause]
you